democrats they're in a full-blown panic
after spending trillions and trillions
and trillions of dollars on handouts our
economy is on fire but not in a good way
breaking today inflation hit a brand new
40-year high on top of last month's 40
air heights even worse accelerating to
7.5 percent in january as market watch
put it quote high inflation has jacked
up the cost of food gas cars rent and
there's little relief in sight in fact
americans are paying almost twice as
much now to fill up their tanks under
biden than they were under president
trump by the way he predicted that and
according to the wall street journal gas
prices will only continue to rise
democrat joe manchin called it an
inflation tax it is quote draining the
hard-earned wages on every american and
it's causing real and severe economic
pain that can no longer be ignored and
get this a new study from a senior
economist at moody's found the average
american household is now spending an
additional
276 bucks a month because of
record-setting inflation the pain is of
obviously hurting the poor in the middle
class in the country the hardest and
obama's own economic adviser lawrence
summers he sees a full-blown recession
in his crystal ball is on its way
and today a very frail looking joe well
he made his way all the way down to
central virginia he really went far
where he's greeted by large crowds of
protesters including
one man with a very special sign that
reads quote
build crack
better
during a speech about biden vowed to
work like the devil to get these prices
under control take a look
i'm going to work like the devil to
bring gas prices down which i'm going to
work in to make sure that we keep
strengthening the supply chains to bring
the cost of energy and everything else
and the goods that come to america
down
by helping the porch 24 7 by changing a
whole range of things that you know
what's happened with covet covet has
caused significant increase in prices in
the supply chain we're in a situation
now where
you know you should have peace of mind
i know food prices are up and we're
working to bring them down as i said i
grew up in a family where
a price at the pump went up you filled
it and i understand
but these things are necessities
joe's going to work like the devil
himself but just don't ask him any tough
questions about it take a look
back in july you said
inflation was going to be temporary i
think a lot of americans are wondering
what your definition of temporary is
well you're being a wise guy with me a
little bit i understand that's your job
being a wise guy a little testy joe in
case you're wondering biden's plan to
curb inflation was to spend three
trillion dollars that in real money was
over five trillion
and guess what that we don't have any
more socialist build back broke handouts
by the way mansion did him a favor so
did cinema now chuck schumer is
terrified of a primary challenge from
alexandria ocasio-cortez is ready
willing to ram through any spending
proposal no matter how large no matter
how irresponsible senator manchin he's
been standing in the way schumer is
reportedly very angry with his colleague
from west virginia but manchin is
literally stopping his own party from
completely destroying the economy which
there are which is kind of on the verge
of collapse as it is it's about time
because the american people have seen
enough look for yourself
you approve of president biden's job
performance we'll look at how bad these
numbers are for the president only four
in 10 americans 41 at the moment approve
of his job performance nearly 6 in 10 58
disapproved that's a tough number early
in the midterm election year for the
president united states now why is this
happening this is fascinating we ask
people what has president biden done for
you that you approve of 56 percent of
americans nearly six in 10 americans
that means a decent amount of democrats
said nothing they disapprove of
everything that has happened
even fake news cnn says nearly 60
percent of americans think joe biden has
done absolutely nothing right nothing at
all now with the midterms fast
approaching joe's fellow democrats
they're trying to pull a fast one on you
they're trying to turn 180 on almost
every issue covered 19 mandates all of a
sudden two weeks ago when republicans
were doing it it was a disaster it was
irresponsible they were going to kill
people now all of a sudden they agree
with those republican governors and they
are now following suit and of course
schools they're saying we need to open
the schools back as soon as as soon as
possible
and most of the talk about climate
change and socialism and new green
dealism and oh that's right packing the
courts in dc statehood all of a sudden
now all that talk has gone away
even beto bozo francis o'rourke who
vowed to confiscate guns damn right
we're going to take your guns in texas
as late as 2021 he's now vowing to
protect and cherish the second amendment
okay watch
americans will who own ar-15s ak-47s
will have to sell them to the government
i fully expect our fellow americans to
turn in their ar-15s and their ak-47s
are you in fact in favor of gun
confiscation
yes hell yes we're going to take your
ar-15 your ak-47 i'm not interested in
taking anything from anyone what i want
to make sure that we do is defend the
second amendment
hell yes
now we're going to defend the second
amendment like almost every other
democrat in the country you got to
understand what's happening here they're
only changing their opinions because of
politics and they love their power that
is more important than anything else
even
for example compromising every so-called
principle they have the base of the
democratic party is filled to the brim
with actual socialists most democrats
don't actually have any firm beliefs at
all they just do whatever they think
will make them popular increase their
political power get them reelected but
they can't rewrite history no amount of
smoke and mirrors and flip-flops can
change reality joe biden he caused
america's terrible 40-year high
inflation joe biden literally has once
again made us dependent on energy the
lifeblood of our economy killed the
excel keystone xl pipeline restricted
oil and gas drilling
all over and exploration all over joe
biden caused the crisis at the southern
border it was easily preventable joe
biden abandoned americans in afghanistan
and buckle up because biden is about to
abandon more americans abroad in ukraine
they're even telling us that look
what are your plans toward american
citizens who are in ukraine and might be
there during an invasion
what scenarios would you put american
troops to rescue and get americans out
there's not that's a world war when
americans and russians start shooting at
one another we're in a very different
world than we've ever been in not even
on behalf of simply evacuating americans
no how how do you do that how to even
find them this is not like i'm hoping
that if in fact he's foolish enough to
go in he's smart enough not to in fact
do anything that would negatively impact
on american citizens have you told him
that
yes
you've told him to that
americans would be a line
that they can't cross
well
i didn't have to tell him that
yeah this is the guy that said we had
all the leverage against the taliban and
abandoned americans there and nobody
talks about it but this show
maybe a couple others
now when you think it can't get any
worse at the white house think again
because joe biden is probably not trying
to be rude here but one of the dumbest
least capable presidents we've ever had
his cognitive decline is precipitous at
this point now joe is steering the
country right off a cliff abroad and
right here at home and never forget it
was biden along with his many democratic
colleagues who called for the police to
be defunded and dismantled they're now
trying to rewrite history on this also
you may remember take a look yes i
support the defund movement because this
is about the
the um
investment
in our communities which have
historically been divested one that i'm
actively engaged in in advocacy for is
the reduction of really truly talking
about um the reduction of our nypd
budget and defunding a six billion
dollar nypd budget this model of saying
not only do we need to defund but we
need to dismantle and start anew
allows us to really re-imagine what
public safety should look like in our
community you know in in many cities in
america over one-third of their city
budget goes to police
so we have to have this conversation
what are we doing the last thing you
need is an up armored humvee coming into
a neighborhood it's like the military
invading they don't know anybody they
become the enemy they're supposed to
protecting these people so my generic
point is that do we agree that we can
redirect some of the funding
yes absolutely
yes we'll redirect the funding away from
the police and police become the enemy
okay like almost every other idiotic
plan pushed by democrats in the last
three years all the results on this have
been catastrophic violent crime is
soaring in every major city and can you
believe it democrats are pretending that
they have nothing to do with the spike
in crime they want you to believe that
it's totally out of their control again
they do not care about truth they don't
care about principles they only want to
say these things to get reelected and
care about their power to that end a
brand new bulletin from biden's dhs
warns that anyone who spreads
misinformation about the us government
might be a terrorist in other words if
you dare to disagree with the
administration you might be labeled a
domestic terrorist by mayorkis and his
dhs
that is beyond chilling and dangerous
and by the way you know the summer of
2020 when all those riots took place
that they ignored when democrats fully
supported nationwide mostly peaceful
protests that killed dozens of people
injured thousands of cops created
billions in property damage arson and
looting well those protests were we were
told were important part of democracy
even when they were violent and deadly
and costly these same democrats are now
vilifying the real peaceful freedom
convoy in canada there's no violence
there's no racism in fact far left
government officials across the border
in ontario they have successfully frozen
donations to the truckers in an effort
to freeze them out so they can't get
fuel for their trucks so they can have
heat inside of their their cabins that
they sleep in the back of their truck
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else